I'm known as an optimist what are you
optimistic about and what is good about
a young generation what to be optimistic
about that they have or that they will
improve that our generation couldn't or
didn't uh they're more talented they're
more skilled with technology and they're
much more socially aware distinctive
some of the issues they face the
challenges they face that we discussed
the more prone to depression social
media technology they are more skilled
they are much more socially conscious
than I ever was they're going to be more
productive and they're going to lead
much better lives they're going to have
cancer vaccines they're going to be able
to help each other the number of people
the best chart of my book adrift
American 100 charts was by the way Simon
you did not bring up once
the best chart in the whole book
is that if you look at the amount of
time people are spending helping people
they will never meet
it's at a record high in every region of
the world people are planting more trees
the shade of which they will not sit
under than in any time in history that's
a reason to be optimistic something's
working